إذن ، أليس هناك قبة
صافرة مذهلة تمامًا ، هذا
ثم تضيء في الليل ،
نعم إنها دراماتيكية للغاية مع المظهر الموسيقي ،
إنه ليس برج إيفل صحيحًا ،
لكنني أعني بالنسبة للمعرض ، هذه
قطعة رائعة حقًا من البنية التحتية
برج إيفل في الصحراء ،
تجربة التنقل لدينا على وشك أن
تبدأ ، وهي في الواقع تبدو وكأنها
رحلة اكتشاف ، أعني أننا
نذهب في مغامرة خيال علمي ، ليس لدي أي
فكرة عما يمكن توقعه ، ألقِ نظرة على هذا
الأمر  هل هذا جنون حقيقي ، إنه مجنون
[موسيقى]
بين إنسان عادي وتلك
النظرة إلى أننا نبدو وكأننا
مرضى صغيرون
هي تلك الفتاة الحقيقية ، الفتاة ليست حقيقية
ما تبدو حقيقية إنها ليست حقيقية
عندما يكون الأطفال هنا  سوف
يحلمون بالكواكب الخارجية
والسفر في الفضاء والأضواء الوامضة
وكل ما كنت تعتقد أن المتوسط كان في ال
قيقة عبءًا حسيًا زائدًا ، فهناك ال
ثير من الأضواء والشاشات الوامضة وا
تجارب ، إن
رائع جدًا لقد كان رائعًا جدًا.  ص
على استعداد للذهاب للتحقق من الجناح الأفريقي ،
فلنقم بذلك ، نعم ،
مرحبًا بكم في الجناح الكيني ، اسمحوا
لي أن أريكم حول الملك والجناح
كيف تقولون مرحبًا بكم في كاريبو السواحيلية
قريبًا بما يكفي ، استمع جيدًا ، لذا فإن كينيا هي كل شيء
عن محاولة
زيادة التصنيع
يركزون على التكنولوجيا المالية وهم يركزون
على الاقتصاد الرقمي ، لذا فإن لدى كينيا
لاري الكثير لتقدمه في الواقع
تمامًا وهي تفتح أبوابًا أكثر من ذلك بكثير ،
فهناك جيل كامل من
رواد الأعمال في الدولة ويمكنك أن
ترى بعضًا من ذلك هنا  طاقة
الإثارة والإثارة التي يقدمونها للمستثمرين
الذين يأتون إلى المعرض ،
لذا يجب أن أريكم شيئًا ما ، نعم ، عن
شعبي ، هؤلاء هم 44
شخصًا مختلفًا في كينيا
وهذا من غرب البلاد ،
حيث أنا من مدينة
لواو.  يمكنك الحصول على مفتاح على الرغم من
أنني لا أحصل حتى على هدية لأنني من
كينيا ، شكرًا يا رفاق ، حسنًا ، دعنا نذهب
بخير ، حسنًا ،
zanzi
zanzi ، دعنا نتحقق من ذلك مرحبًا
بكم في جناح جنوب إفريقيا o  حسنًا ، هذا
رائع
[تصفيق]
إنه نجم
، لقد أحضرت نجمًا رائعًا ،
لدي سؤال ، لدي
سؤال ، هل أحضرتم لي يا رفاق
knickknacks
[ضحك]
تعلمون أن أحد الأشياء التي أحببتها
في العيش في جنوب إفريقيا الأطلنطي  ما
مقدار الثقافة
واللون الذي تتمتع به الدولة والناس
فخورون بها ولكن لا تحب أيضًا
أنك تعلم أنه كان هناك الكثير من
التسامح
مع بعضنا البعض 100 جميع الثقافات
للغات ولكن أعتقد أن جنوب إفريقيا
هي الأكثر تصنيعًا  بلد
في القارة ، إنه مصانع معالجة ،
إنه رائع حقًا ،
هذا هو المكان الذي أتيت منه في
بومالانجا وأنا من بلدة صغيرة لتعدين الفحم
، سبرينغبوك أحب أن أكرههم
لأنه Springbok المفضل لدينا ، حسنًا ،
هذا هو الحاضر الذي
أكره هؤلاء الرجال لأنهم  إنهم دائمًا
ما يهزمون الفريق الكيني في 7 ديسمبر في
كل مرة ، نحن
الأبطال وأكره ذلك ،
لقد كان هذا أمرًا رائعًا ، انظروا إلى أنه كان لا يزال
يزرع المكعب الذي ترى أن الكثير من الناس
يريدون الحصول عليه  يكرر